students at schools and universities
across the country will leave their
classrooms as part of the national
school walkout tomorrow morning the 17
minute action will honor the 17 victims
of the Stoneman Douglas High School
shooting in Florida last month
participants are protesting existing gun
laws and demanding change in her latest
New York Times article psychologists and
CBS News contributor Lisa d'amour
explains why activism could be good for
kids Lisa joins us at the table Lisa
good morning good morning so tell us
what the studies show about activism so
this new study that came out not that
long ago shows that teenagers who
participate in activism go on to higher
levels of education and higher incomes
than teenagers who don't and the really
remarkable thing about the study is that
this was true even when they accounted
for those teenagers early grades in
school and their parents education
levels which are usually the factors
that drive later success so it doesn't
prove that activism actually you know
leads to high achievement but it makes a
very strong case for it why do you think
that's true well so here's what the
researchers thought they thought that
kids who get engaged in activism do
three things they may develop
professional skills it may plug them
into social networks and it also may
develop their belief their beliefs in
their own capacities I also love this
idea of it encourages them to see
possibilities in the future talk about
that a little bit more broadly with
adolescents because when you think about
the It Gets Better campaign and other
things isn't it about teaching them hey
it's not all what's happening today life
is long and I think you know people are
thinking whoa okay so what does it mean
just to walk out of school for 17
minutes what difference is that gonna
make and I think that the way we want to
think about it is if it plugs them in to
ongoing engagement if it makes them
think about broad social causes that's
good for teenagers I think another way
we think about it is that we're always
complaining that they're on their phones
they're obsessed with themselves they're
disconnected from the world you know so
I think that's also true true but I
think that when they're saying we want
to be engaged we want to be connected we
want to be connected to students around
the country I think that that's
something we need to think carefully
about the implications the study also
showed how voting and volunteering
affects physical and mental health
differently than activism that's really
interesting this
interesting so they looked at three
forms of civic engagement they looked at
voting volunteering and activism all
three conferred these later benefits to
achievement and income activism alone
actually was also connected to higher
levels of risky behavior so that one was
interesting so the researchers in
explaining that they had a couple of
ideas one was they said you know
historically activists have sometimes
belonged to counterculture groups where
maybe risky behavior is more typical
that maybe less true you know when now
the students tomorrow are expressing in
many ways widely held view they also
said that activism is frustrating you
know and the people who are heavily
engaged in activism may become you know
sort of frustrated and turned to smoking
or drinking but inherent in activism is
a backlash as well
well activism would not disagree much
yeah yeah and and we need to prepare
teenage what's a response yeah how do
parents help without ruining it the way
we do everything the sense of your
parent is cheering you want is it still
activism you know I think that we don't
make it about the parent-child
relationship we make it about connecting
to other teenagers connecting to a
broader cause connecting to something
the teenagers engaged in for their own
reasons and for their own sort of
motivations and prepare them for the
backlash you say but and don't let them
know - this is a good thing
it is a good thing and that they also
have to disagree in ways that are
constructive and respectful alright
thank you very much Lisa tomorrow it's
good to have you here thank you